in just two short minutes a teaser
trailer for the upcoming Ahsoka Disney
plus series provides a wide array of
references for Star Wars fans to catch
the Ahsoka trailer hits the ground
running featuring numerous returning
characters from Star Wars Rebels most
ominously we get our first live-action
look at Grand Amaral thrawn fans have
known since season two of The
Mandalorian that Ahsoka was after the
cheers military officer but we now know
he's coming where is your master
where is Grand Admiral thrawn to make
Star Wars fans even more excited the
titular Jedi mentions that she's heard
Whispers of thrawn's return as heir to
the Empire while some may see this as a
throwaway line to Simply set up this new
villain's presence fans of the extended
universe will immediately recognize a
reference to thrawn's first appearance
in Timothy zahn's novel of that name the
novel story takes place five years after
the battle of Endor and the defeat of
the Empire Grand Amaral thrawn gathers
his Imperial forces including a clone of
Jedi Master drawer sabayath becoming a
massive threat to the new Republic the
fan favorite novel is the first enzymes
Trilogy introducing thrawn to the Star
Wars universe and many consider it the
go-to thrawn story if Luca's film is
adapting parts of it for the character's
Arc and Ahsoka and fans are in for quite
the trees
another foreboding figure in the Ahsoka
trailer is a Darkly dressed Force user
played by Ray Stevenson he's not
directly named but he is calm cool and
collected even as he ruthlessly attacks
a group of rebels however since Ahsoka
isn't wasting any time by showing that
grand Amaral thrawn will be a major
player it wouldn't be too far as fresh
to think that Stevenson's character
might be from the same book series where
thrawn originated also introduced an ad
to the Empire Jorah sabayath is a dark
Jedi that is instrumental in many of
thrawn's plans he is actually a clone of
a slain Jedi Master with nearly the same
Name a former friend of Emperor
Palpatine clones are usually designated
with a misspelled name in the world of
Star Wars and considering that cloning
plays a major role throughout Star Wars
it would make sense if Ahsoka features a
clone Jedi to highlight that this has
been a process spanning decades whoever
Stevenson is playing is sure to be of
great interest whether it be jaurus or
some other character and it will be
fascinating to see how he connects to
thrawn
Ahsoka won't be short of Space Battles
and threads that will pose challenges
for Our Heroes people will suffer Peril
will before the Galaxy but the people
behind the Star Wars franchise also
understand that cute furry creatures can
help launch successful merchandising
campaigns along with serving as comic
relief between the big battles Ahsoka
will continue this trend with two cacats
these orange Critters are adorable but
they do more than sit around looking
pretty tukas are known for their hunting
skills and they're mostly used for
getting rid of pests the creatures have
appeared in live action Star Wars
products before most recently on the
Mandalorian where they can be spotted
rummaging through garbage and stalling
at grogu the tsuka cat and the Ahsoka
trailer looks friendlier than some of
its peers and this big Cameo suggests
that it might be the most significant
such feline to Grace a Star Wars
franchise to date
near the start of the trailer Rosario
Dawson statue of character and Chiefs
are lightsabers and proceeds to use the
force to spin them around and open up a
hole in the ground it seems like she's
getting ready for battle as she's used
the same maneuver during dangerous
situations in the past this move is
actually a reference to a bigger Soca
moment from Star Wars the Clone Wars she
performs a similar move so that she and
Rex can escape a group of clones during
order 66. it's a subtle moment in the
trailer but Eagle Light Star Wars fans
will instantly recognize her
the Ahsoka trailer includes a seeming
nod to underworld and we don't mean the
unproduced Star Wars and the world TV
series which would have chronicled
organized crime in the city of Coruscant
know the apparent underworld nod here is
the 2003 film of the name in which
vampires and werewolf like lichens
battle for monstrous Supremacy for those
like me a death dealer this signaled the
end of an era when Ahsoka cuts a hole in
the stone floor and drops down into an
underground lair it's definitely
reminiscent of when it came back in
sales vampire Hunter Celine blasts
herself through a floor and lands the
same way in the first Underworld movie
Ahsoka and underworld both revolve
around butt kicking women and this nice
to see the Star Wars series give a shout
out to the entertaining action horror
Blockbuster
it looks like Ahsoka will give Star Wars
Rebels fans plenty to chew on as it
picks up by the Animated Series left off
at one point in the trailer Sabine
stands on a tower watching as ahsoka's
T6 shuttle flies overhead the scene is a
direct reference to rebels in the final
episode of that series The Ghost crew
have all gone their separate ways five
years after the battle of Endor Sabine
remains on lothar watching over the
capital city from a tower when ahsoka's
ship flies past the Mandalorian the
leaves lothal with a Jedi assisting her
in a search for Ezra the virgin in the
Ahsoka trailer is nearly a shop perfect
remake bringing the two characters
reunion to live action
Rogue one gave fans one of the greatest
Star Wars scenes of all time with Darth
Vader cutting down an army of soldiers
in the hallway it looks like those new
Republic recruits will be victims of a
similar attack in Ahsoka in the new
trailer Ray Stevenson's new Sith takes
on a small group of New Republic
troopers on a ship he effortlessly to
flex her Blaster shots as he walks
closer and closer the brief scene is
only reminiscent of Vader's climatic
ending in Rogue one not to mention Darth
Maul's hallway scene from Clone Wars one
soldier gets a force choke treatment
while the others don't really look to
have anywhere to hide Star Wars Rebel
Star Freddie Prince Jr claims on the
lights camera Barstool podcast that Dave
filoni the showrunner of Ahsoka directed
the iconic Rogue one scene
early on in the Ahsoka teaser trailer
we're introduced to the live-action
version of Sabine Wren played by Natasha
Lube or dizzo the character first
appeared in the Animated Series Star
Wars Rebels which takes place in the
early years of the Rebellion prior to
the events of the original Star Wars
Sabine is a Mandalorian warrior who
helps reunite her people by claiming the
darksaber from her adversaries though
it's been years since she wielded the
blade Sabine has no doubt retained all
the skill sets of a seasoned Warrior
prior to the ending of Rebels Sabine
develops a strong bond with her fellow
member of the ghost crew aka the
specters Ezra Bridger who disappears
Suddenly at the end of the Rebel story
in the series finale family reunion and
farewell the specters dissolve with
Ahsoka and Sabine departing for the
stars and search of their missing Ally
since Ahsoka takes place years after
Return of the Jedi in step with the
Mandalorian it's unclear if these two
are still hoping to find their missing
comrade or if they've given up the
search entirely with thrawn returning to
threaten the Galaxy Sabine will likely
be close behind since the grand Amaral
was the last one to see Ezra alive
she'll probably want a few words with
the Imperial warlord regarding her
friend's whereabouts nevertheless as a
Mandalorian culture continues to rebuild
we hope to see Sabine take part in her
people's continued Legacy maybe she'll
even reunite with Boca tan down the line
a long time staple of the Star Wars
Universe mon mothma has been a leader in
the Rebellion for as long as they've
been around though she first appeared in
Return of the Jedi she was a rebel long
before the original trilogy in fact
actress Genevieve O'Reilly who replaced
the original trilogy actress Caroline
Blackiston first played the character in
George Lucas's third prequel installment
Revenge of the Sith though only in a
deleted scene O'Reilly returned to Star
Wars in the Standalone prequel film
Rogue one and has since later a growing
part in the franchise after a larger
role in the series Andor O'Reilly
returns as a rebel leader here possibly
to Aid Ahsoka in a search for Ezra
Bridger though it only appears a handful
of times in the series the lothal Jedi
Temple was a Mystic a megalithic sight
where Jedi Masters would bring their
padawans to determine their promise as
potential Jedi Knights In Rebels Ahsoka
and Kanan jarus take Ezra to the temple
as a rite of passage eventually the site
which serves as a gateway to the world
Between Worlds is severed and access to
the temple is cut off as it sinks below
the surface office years later Luke
Skywalker attempts to find the temple in
Marvel Star Wars comic series only to
lose a connection admittedly Ahsoka
might not be at the lothal temple at all
but if she were to attempt a connection
with the world Beyond worlds it seems
like the first and possibly only place
to start after the Empire takes power
Jedi temples become few and far between
with many of them broken Beyond repair
this is why Luke is seen constructing a
brand new Jedi Temple during the events
of the book of Boba Fett whatever
ahsoka's reasons are for investigating
the temple it's clear that she has a
mission that she's going to see through
there are plenty of notable Astro Meg
Droids that have graced different
episodes of the greater Star Wars Canon
and while none are more famous than the
original R2D2 Chopper is in a category
of his own mischievous and Tibet
prejudice against other droids Chopper
isn't so different from your standard R2
unit if you discount the mini pincers
sprouting out of his head naturally he
sticks out like a sore thumb in the
Ahsoka teaser aside from his animated
appearances Chopra has only shown up in
live-action Star Wars on one brief
occasion in the form of a cameo in Rogue
one that said Ahsoka will Mark the fun
favorite droid's first official
appearance in live-action Star Wars
confirming his place in the post-return
of the Jedi world and where Chopper is
the rest of the ghost crew won't be far
behind after garozzeb Aurelio's made his
live-action debut in Season three of the
Mandalorian it doesn't come into
surprise that the rest of the specters
would follow
speaking of the specters Harrison Doula
played by Mary Elizabeth Winstead is
also seen in the Ahsoka teaser now a
general in the new Republic this
Twilight pilot has continued the fight
long after the death of her partner
Kanan Jairus who gave his life to save
the ghost crew near the end of rebels
appearing in the Clone Wars spin-off
Star Wars the bad batch a young Hera
appears in a two-part episode that
provides some necessary backstory for
her hatred of the Empire the Empire's
taken my parents
continuing on to Rebels Hera worked
alongside Ahsoka in a rebel cell
stationed around the local system
pushing back against Imperial enemies
like Grand Admiral thrawn needless to
say Hera has some real experience and is
often considered the best pilots in the
Rebellion even better than Luke
Skywalker or Han Solo although her share
for the ghost has seen briefly in the
rise of Skywalker it's unclear how long
hero outlives her Companions and the
greatest Star Wars timeline hopefully
Ahsoka will keep her in the game for as
long as possible following her guest
appearance on the Mandalorian Ahsoka was
on a mission to find Grand Admiral
thrawn and end his reign of terror for
good in her ways that Morgan ellsbeth a
servant of Thrones who's completely
devoted to the Empire but with the
Empire and shambles and the new Republic
on the rise it stands to reason natal's
Beth returned to the Shadows to do her
Masters bidding outside of the public
eye Ahsoka may be tracking her down for
more information but there's another
possibility as well the Droid guards
that Ahsoka battles in the teaser at
presumably the Jedi Temple ruins are the
same ones who work for Ellsworth in fact
Ahsoka and dinjarin battled them when
their past first crossed while we know
very little about Elizabeth's history
many believe that she may actually be
one of the Knight sisters a group of
witches from dathomir nevertheless Elbas
returns signals that thrawn himself
isn't far behind and that he means
serious business
arguably the main character of Star Wars
Rebels Ezra Bridger is one of the most
impressive Jedi to ever travel the
Galaxy trained by his master Kanan jarus
Ezra goes from a force sensitive Misfit
into a full-fledged Jedi Knight
throughout the series after his
disappearance at the end of rebels what
happens to Ezra is one of the biggest
unanswered questions in all of Star Wars
with the deep space whale-like creatures
the perguel appearing Albia briefly in
recent episodes of the Mandalorian
there's hope that we'll discover where
they took Ezra and thrawn after the
events of the animated series with
thrawn's return upon us and plenty of
other animated characters coming to life
in live action there's little doubt that
we'll be seeing Ezra Bridges soon enough
hopefully we United with his friends of
course it's entirely possible that Ezra
played by Iman as fondi in Ahsoka won't
appear in anything more than Holograms
and flashback sequences but with
thrawn's arrival it would be a shame if
Ezra didn't make a real appearance as
well
only appearing in a single shot in the
Ahsoka trailer is the professor Droid
huyang known for his time and service to
the Jedi Order but over a thousand
Generations who Yang taught different
Jedi younglings away of the force and
their Jedi history alongside his two
tillage he also instructed young Jedi on
constructing their very own lightsabers
preparing them for their intensive
Padawan training in Star Wars the Clone
Wars Ahsoka troubles with the Droid and
a group of younglings as they gather
their Kiva crystals which almost
destroys the ancient Professor we don't
know what happened to huyang between the
events of Order 66 and the destruction
of the Empire but we do know that he
seems to be talking with Ahsoka here
it's possible that this scene is
actually set during the Clone Wars but
it's also possible that the old Droid
survived to the present day to help
rebuild the Jedi Order
while it's mentally unclear if this is
indeed the famed World between World
scene and Star Wars Rebels the teaser
trailer shows Ahsoka arriving at a
ruin's temple from the glyphs to map
scene during the sequence some have
noted that the former Jedi may be
attempting to enter the world Between
Worlds later in the trailer Ahsoka has
seen battling balance skull in a space
that looks somewhat similar to Ezra's
time in the otherworldly space the world
Between Worlds from Star Wars Rebels
allows its guests to experience and even
interact with various timelines only
Ezra Bridger has been known to break
into this Force sensitive space for the
sake of saving Ahsoka from being killed
by her former Master Darth Vader though
he attempted to save his own Master as
well Ezra recognized that the timeline
changes would be too severe and cost the
lives of his friends
Kanan found the moment when he was
needed
though we don't know why Ahsoka might be
trying to enter the world Between Worlds
we do know that it's a truly unique
space that the Star Wars Universe has
kept at arm's length time travel can be
dangerous after all
in the Ahsoka teaser trailer we see a
young woman named shinharti who Wheels
an orange lightsaber and seems to exude
Dark Side energy an apparent villain
Shin is on the hunt for Ahsoka and might
be The Apprentice of balance Skol clad
in a dark hood and a darker skull her
violent and impulsive nature as a direct
contrast to that of Ahsoka after years
of training under Anakin Skywalker
Ahsoka learned that her emotions could
be controlled and channeled into
something more useful one addition to
Jedi lore that was featured in the
prequel trilogy was a single braid that
Jedi padawans wore to signify their
tutelage under a Jedi master they
weren't Masters themselves and they were
yet to be Knights making their training
Paramount to their education in the
force in the teaser Shin seems to
support her own Padawan braid though
this tradition diesels after the fall of
the Jedi Order it could make a comeback
during the New Republic era if shin and
Balan really are stiff they may have
ties to Our Heroes past or the Clone
Wars era on the other hand the orange
lightsabers as opposed to the classic
red Sabers wielded by Seth inquisitors
and and Padawan braid might mean that
shin and her master aren't quite as
malevolent as they seem aside from being
a valiant Warrior Sabine Wren is also an
artist in the Ahsoka teaser there are a
few pieces of art on her wall while she
glances at a hologram of her Fallen
companion Ezra Bridger behind her we see
a sketch of a pile of rocks somewhat
reminiscent of the Rocks Yoda uses to
train Luke Skywalker's skill patience
and concentration in Empire Strikes Back
but that isn't the only art worth noting
directly to the left of sabine's head is
an image of a wolf-like creature this is
most likely a loath Wharf a species
native to Ezra's Homeworld of lothal
that often acts as Spirit guides to
force sensitive beings usually Guardians
of the Light Side the loathwarves aided
Ezra in the past likewise Sabine has
drawn a few loath cats on her walls no
doubt companions to the actual loath cat
she owns in her home these felines are
also native to Ezra's home world and are
likely constant reminders to Sabine of
his loss
the teaser also shows glimpses of a
battle between Ahsoka and a red
lightsaber-wielding opponent who may be
a member of the inquisitors well most of
these assassins were defeated prior to
Return of the Jedi it's certainly
possible that there are still a few out
there hoping to eradicate the surviving
Jedi from the Galaxy throughout Star
Wars Rebels Obi-Wan Kenobi and the
Marvel Comics The inquisitors have
mercilessly hunted nearly every
surviving Jedi post Order 66 though they
failed to kill some of the most
important thankfully Ahsoka seems to
gain the upper hand and proves herself a
formidable opponent after seeing the
inquisitors in live-action during the
Disney plus Obi-Wan Kenobi series it
would certainly be exciting to see these
villains show up again going forward
what's especially compelling about this
group of Jedi Killers is that many of
them were trained directly by Darth
Vader himself meaning that much of
ahsoka's training under Anakin Skywalker
most likely overlaps with their own
[Music]
foreign